hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to a while
ago an article appeared online making
the very grim claim that in the last
episode of Tom and Jerry they apparently
committed suicide if you search the
internet even more you'd find there's
actually a lot of articles claiming the
same thing that in the last animated
short by hanna-barbera the episode
grimly ends with them sitting on the
railroad tracks waiting for death to
take them this could possibly be true
could it but upon more research you'd
find that some channels have banned the
episode and even to this day it gets you
if any showings on American TV holy shit
this might actually be legit did the
world's most hilariously violin team up
and their days and the most disturbing
way possible I mean we all know we'd see
them in other projects and even
somewhere we wish they were dead but did
the original creators hanna-barbera
really do this to them did hanna-barbera
really do something so terrible to tour
the most famous icons sorry there's a
bit more to the story the episode in
question is called blue cat boobs and
yes it does open up with Tom sitting on
the railroad tracks waiting to be run
over Jerry watch is shaking his head and
through an inner monologue gives us the
story apparently Tom and Jerry used to
be the best of friends but don't worry
they still get smashed up pretty good
until a female comes into their lives
and ruins everything
tom falls in love pushing Jerry aside
but then she falls in love with another
cat Tom does everything to try and win
her back
even selling an arm and a leg for her
but absolutely nothing works eventually
she ends up getting married to the other
cat resulting in Todd being so beaten
and torn that he lays himself on the
tracks
cheeri of course justifies with a
perfect relationship he's got only to
find out his girlfriend as well ran off
with someone else resulting in him
asking Tom if he can scoot over a bit um
dem Dame's a bros before animal eyes
kind of humanistic hos okay so there's a
few angles to come in this room what Tom
and Jerry have been squashed smashed
beaten hit with every object you can
imagine I think it's more than likely
they would survive a train but then
again
flexible reality can go both ways
The Addams Family for example have done
a lot that would obviously kill them but
a bullet from a gun or threat of
electrocution apparently our fatal blows
you could also make the argument that
their acceptance of their doom is what
suddenly launches them into reality gray
area to be sure but there's also the
fact that Tom and Jerry's timeline
doesn't follow much continuity every
episode is a little different the house
looks a little different the owners a
little different help
Jerry's adopt his son nibbles is left on
his doorstep God knows how many times
what does it just keep sending him back
after every adventure that's gonna do
she so again kind of a flexible reality
most importantly though well this is one
of the final episodes it's not the final
episode the final episode is actually
called top watchers and they don't
commit suicide they look after a baby a
fucking baby a touch less depressing
don't you think in fact hanna-barbera
still had two years of cartoons that
came out after the supposed last episode
so it's pretty obvious this was meant
not to be the end for a depressed duo so
then while the controversy are banning
from other channels
well because Tom and Jerry ending their
lives is kind of a fucking doubt people
sensitivities have changed over time to
race gender and yes even some forms of
violence now that's not to say people
haven't also died from shootings and
falling off high places and so forth but
the tone is still kept pretty upbeat and
in a different reality this though still
the punchline of a joke is pretty heavy
to watch for two main characters we know
and love so much though again I argue
not quite as hard to watch as this breed
achieve my answer should be nc-17 I
remember seeing this episode when I was
a little kid and I wasn't at all
disturbed by it I got the joke Jerry
thinks he's being above it all and that
could never happen to him and when it
does happen to him he comedic Lee does
the exact same thing but as much as I
love grim humor not every little kid is
going to get it and could easily take it
too seriously hell if the Internet has
shown us anything is that even adults
can take it too seriously
so did Tom and Jerry commit suicide in
the last episode not really we never see
them get axed off they survive much
worse it's obviously the punchline of a
joke and most importantly they have
about a dozen cartoons after this
one if this demonstrates anything is
that we've grown more sensitive to
certain jokes in connection with certain
characters a suicide joke in an episode
of Louie wouldn't be that big a deal but
in Tom and Jerry yeah many people can
get uncomfortable but in terms of any
grand shocking ending people are looking
for it's certainly not here it's a funny
little episode with what they thought at
the time was a funny little ending in
the end it's not as epic or gothic as
many would suspect it's just a silly
joke about obsessing over Romans 10
really when is anything related to
romance in the media ever cause anybody
to commit suicide
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh